what are you doing
i'm good how are you doing i'm i'm doing
good your speed dating continues
uh let me start by saying uh how
fantastic this movie is
um and your performance i have nothing
uh
it's just one of those really really
great films
um i have to ask you about meeting with
steve mcqueen for the first time because
i think he's such a talented filmmaker
uh i guess i'll start with the most
important question um how much did you
pay
to work with him i paid nothing
um i went on holiday to trinidad and
tobago
um it was like the week of black panther
coming out so i was like i need to do
something
um and i got the script in trinidad and
tobago and then
i had to land from my trip and meet
steve
so i went and met him and the classic
director
and we were just talking and i was just
like why do you want to do this
and he gave me a really good answer you
know that our
our elders are you know the the gap and
the time for them to see the story and
see themselves represented is passing
away
so we need to do something about them
and put something out there that's going
to be
worthy enough to to represent them and
make them proud
and i was like sold so i was just like
okay cool so where do i audition
and what scenes do you want me to
audition and he was just like you just
auditioned take the script go home and
learn it and now
we're going to be on set and i was like
yeah stop playing with me
you know i need to you know everybody
makes me audition and
learn 5 000 lines and you know do the
normal thing of
of auditioning and he's like no i trust
you i've seen your work
um gary senior work our casa director
and
you know he's like i didn't make michael
fassbender do it so i shouldn't make you
do it
i was like i'm so confused you're
telling me you're gonna trust me to lead
this fig like
and he's like yes and then i was like
okay
so i went home and i just prayed about
it and i was like okay cool i can do it
if he says i can do it
i can do it and i'm honored that he
would
feel so confident about me and my talent
um and to give me the responsibility and
the honor of playing althea jones laquan
and trusting me to do so so i hope he's
proud
with the result of trusting me
please i i think everyone that goes
without saying
uh uh uh when was the last time and
maybe it isn't on this particular movie
i'm curious
when was when do you remember the last
time you were really nervous
before doing something on set and why
every time um
i think i was the last time i was really
nervous about doing something on set
would definitely be the scene that i had
to do
um it was a the courtroom scene i had to
do
after um althea does her final
you know kind of like
uh trial run with whoever she was um
cross-examining
and that scene was so nervous for me i
was so nervous
for it because um i just didn't we
didn't have
marks we we did we didn't come on trying
to plan it and plan
your plan the emotion it was raw it was
really raw
the camera's got the camera guys had to
be ready cinematographer shabir
this focus puller just had to be ready
and steve was just like
get everything that you need within um
within your spirit and let's go
and i was nervous because i wanted to
nail it i wanted to i wanted to
i wanted it to be honest and truthful um
and we had we did it maybe like two
maximum three times
and i was just nervous i was just like
man like i just want to
get the truth that i've been holding
within me of this scene
out and thankfully we got to do that so
but i always get nervous i guess if
you're not nervous that's that
maybe there's a problem something's
wrong with you i think uh one of the
things
if steve had just made this film i would
have been impressed
very impressed but he chose to make five
films
uh all dealing with this powerful
subject matter
and i've seen two of the five and
they're both spectacular
how the f does he do this um i think he
tricked us
um so we uh we signed up for tv shows i
was just like this is tv shows
but then he kept saying we're shooting
we're shooting film and we shot on film
too
by the way and um and he's just like
we're shooting on film
shooting film don't tell anybody that
though
uh so you just kept doing it you just
kept putting it into our minds these
features
it's like six features feature films
it's not tv it's feature
it's like great cool feature film tv
like it's not tv it's feature
so i think he just put it into our heads
on set and then he got away with
it yeah no i mean
he is he's really such a great filmmaker
and and
the thing that i i think it's so
important that this subject matter
gets talked about again and again and
again it's
and also it's very timely and this look
for mangrove about just looking at
institutional racism
and discrimination it's just so
important can you sort of talk about
um the importance of a film like this
and shining a light on
you know systemic everything that it's
talking about
uh it's definitely important of course
because it informs us about what
happened before
and it helps us to see what's happening
now but for me
i'll just speak solely for myself
i look forward to a day where we don't
ever have to make a film
or a documentary or a newspaper article
or in or see on the news of
there being systemic racism of their
being police brutality
towards another person um
[Music]
my hope is that we can get
a great understanding of it as a
humanity and cross that bridge together
where we don't
ever have to speak about this again
because it's
it's too much to bear sometimes um
so though the the project and all
projects like it
are amazing informative amazing and
honorable to be a part of
the hope is that one day we never have
to be in a situation where we have to
even
have art imitating life and life
imitating art
uh completely um one of the things that
steve does so well
um in this film and in his work is tr it
feels like you've been transported to
another time and place
um what is it like stepping on or what
was it like for you stepping on set
and the energy there because it just
felt like you were
somewhere else it was really cool um
they did
all they could um tangibly could to
get the right cars there the costume the
sets
the hair makeup everything that we could
um
have tangible to us to feel like that
world
is is is is real like we're really in
the 60s
and also we just kind of like just
drowned ourselves in archive videos and
and um and material but also being on
set yeah
the vibe and the energy was definitely
there um and all those little pieces
costume clothes um props everything just
kind of brings you into that world
really nicely yeah and that oh i was
gonna say on that note i need to go and
i mean it sincerely
fantastic performance great film thank
you
have a great day you too